at 11 27
we know from video evidence 1127
the exterior door
suspected
of what the
where we knew the the shooter entered
ramos
was propped open by a teacher
11 28
the suspect vehicle crashes into the
ditch as previously described
the teacher runs to the room 132 to
retrieve a phone and that same team
teacher walks back to the exit door
and door remains propped open
for two males as reported by
regional director escalant yesterday
there were two males at a funeral home
that when they heard the crash they went
to the crash scene
when they arrived at the crash scene
before they got there they saw a man
with a gun exit the passenger's side
with a backpack
they immediately began running
ramos began shooting at him did not hit
him
one of the males
fell when he was running
both males returned the funeral home
while they're running
and then again
we see through video
teacher re-emerges inside the school and
panic and apparently calls 9-1-1
9-1-1 call at 11 30.
there was a crash man with a gun
11 31
the suspect reaches last row of vehicles
in the school parking lot
11 31 the suspect shooting began
at the school while patrol vehicles
got to the funeral home i'll point out
where it is
fresh vehicles over here
suspects
sliding behind a vehicle
started walking down shooting into the
classroom
there's a discussion early on that an
isd
consolidated isd for uvaldi
that officer was a resource officer and
had confronted
the substance that did not happen
as rds colon talked about yesterday
it was certainly stated in preliminary
interviews but often these preliminary
interviews and a cursory walk through
doesn't reveal the type of information
and certainly the police officers like
anyone else under stress sometimes
witnesses get it wrong
but the bottom line is that officer was
not on scene not on campus
but had heard the
a gun 911 immediately to the area
sped to what he thought was the man with
a gun
to the back of the school what turned
out to be a teacher
and not the suspect
in doing so he drove right by the
suspect who was hunkered down behind a
vehicle where he began
shooting at the school
1131
the suspect shooting in between the
vehicle is when it began while the troll
vehicle gets to the funeral home
multiple shots are fired outside the
school at 11 31
patrol car accelerates on the parking
lot drives by the shooter that's exactly
what i was talking about it was the isd
officer at that time
he passes then leaves the camera view
there's multiple shots fired at the
school at 11 32
at 11 32 27 11 32 36
and 11 33 is when the suspect entered
the school at the door that i'm pointing
to now
11 33 the suspect begins shooting into
room 111
or 112. it's not possible to determine
from the video angle that we have at
this point in time
we do know this
that he shot more than 100 rounds based
on the audio evidence
at that time at least 100 rounds
he entered at 11 33
or
11 33 he started shooting in the
classrooms well at 111 and 112.
at 11 35 three police officers entered
the same door as the suspect entered all
three of those police officers worked
for the uvalde police department
they were later followed by another for
a team of evolving police officers three
and also a
county sheriff county deputy sheriff
a total of seven officers were on the
scene
the three initial police officers that
arrived
went directly to the door and two
received grazing wounds at that time
from the suspect
while the door was closed
not
11
available
at 11 51
a police sergeant and usb agent started
to arrive
in 1203
you know officers
continued to arrive in the hallway
and there were as many as 19 officers at
that time in that hallway
at 12 15 we know that vortech members
arrived
not the entire vortec but members of
vortech
along with shields at 12 21.
the suspect fired again
was believed to be at the door
11 21 law enforcement moved down the
hallway
at 11 50
they breached the door using keys
that they're able to get from the
janitor
because both doors were locked though
both of the classrooms that he shot into
were locked
when officers arrived
they killed the suspect
at that time
and now i'd like to go over the the 911
timeline
which i'll warn you it's not not
it's better that i read it than you
listen to it
they call her identified
i'll not say her name
but she was in room 112 called 9113
the duration of the call was one minute
23 seconds she identified herself and
whispered she's in room 112.
at 12 10
she called back in room 12 advisor
multiple dead
12 13
again she called on the phone again at
12 16 she's called back and said there
was eight to nine students alive
at 12 19
the 911 call was made and
then another person in room 111 called
i will not say her name
she hung up when another student told
her to hung up
12 21 you could hear
over the 911 call three shots were fired
at 12 36
911 call it lasted
for 21
seconds
the
initial caller called back
student child called back
was told to stay on the line and be very
quiet she told 91 that he shot the door
at approximately 12 43 and 12 47 she
asked 911 to please send the police now
at 12 46
she said she could not she that she
could hear the police next door
at 12 50 shots are fired they can be
heard of the 911 call and 1251 is very
loud and sounds like the officers are
moving children out of the room
at that time
the first child that called was outside
before the call cuts off